¿La siguiente tabla representa una ecuación
lineal? Veamos qué está pasando aquí. Cuando
x = -7, y = 4; luego cuando x = -3, y = 3, así
que veamos cuál fue nuestro cambio en x. Entonces,
nuestro cambio en x, incluso podríamos escribirlo
aquí, nuestro cambio en x: al pasar de -7 a -3
tuvimos un incremento de 4 en x, ¿y cuál fue
nuestro cambio en y? Y este triángulo es la
letra griega delta [Δ], la usamos para denotar
el cambio. Bueno, nuestro cambio en y cuando x
aumentó en 4, nuestro valor de y pasó de 4 a 3,
entonces nuestro cambio en y es -1. Ahora, para
que esto sea una ecuación lineal, la razón entre
nuestro cambio en y y nuestro cambio en x tiene
que ser constante, entonces nuestro cambio en y
sobre el cambio en x para dos puntos cualesquiera
de esta ecuación, o dos puntos cualesquiera
en la tabla, tiene que ser la misma constante:
cuando x cambió en 4, y cambió en -1, o cuando
y cambió en -1, x cambió en 4. Entonces tenemos
que tener un cambio constante en y con respecto
a x de -1/4. Veamos si esto es cierto. Así que
en los siguientes dos puntos, cuando vamos de -3
a 1, una vez más estamos aumentando x en 4, y una
vez más estamos disminuyendo y en -1, entonces
tenemos la misma razón. Ahora veamos este último
punto. Cuando pasamos de 1 a 7 en la dirección
x, estamos aumentando en 6 y cuando pasamos de
2 a 1 seguimos disminuyendo en 1, así que ahora
esta razón, partiendo de este tercer punto a este
cuarto punto, es igual a -1 / 6, entonces no
es una ecuación lineal. Déjenme aclarar esto.
Así que nuestro cambio entre estos dos últimos
puntos aquí, nuestro cambio en y = -1 y nuestro
cambio en x = 6, de modo que tenemos una tasa de
cambio diferente de y con respecto a x. Debido a
que tuvimos una tasa de cambio diferente de y con
respecto a x, o la razón entre nuestro cambio en
y y el cambio en x es diferente, esta no es una
ecuación lineal, no, no es una ecuación lineal.